purpose is something that is essential
to us if we pay attention to it yeah and
we have evidence that not always the
societies and businesses organizations
have the awareness and consciousness to
put it into their agenda people wake up
in the morning without purpose everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
Sock'em we're on-site at the beautiful
transformative technology conference for
our second partnership with them we are
now going to be speaking with Agnes SD
Bay hello hi thanks for coming on the
program
we got the look
we got the look you already know it's
coming all the good questions already
for all of the are you okay all right
how about are we really all one as you
say that's the word to category like to
characterize exactly that one is the
number one and that's how we actually
are united
I mean oneness is something that we
rediscover I mean evolutionary always
been one and now we kind of lost it in a
way of evolution and now we're kind of
coming back to our true nature and
there's so many ways to go from there
how about how do you know that we are
one there are multiple ways how we
experience oneness let's take an example
with kids you would see yourself be
mirrored back to yourself every day
especially because the kids they are
acquiring were there sometimes acquiring
something that actually is helpful and
sometimes it is kind of
imposed on them but generally because
they are presumably neutral to the world
they are good mirrors and then you would
see yourself in those mirrors and
therefore you would see actually that
there is no way for you to escape
yourself and the same mirrors they are
just a little bit more foggy when you
speak with the adults but then kids are
the best to remind you here you are and
we are here together and we're gonna be
together and this is how I see that we
constantly reflect back on each other
the oneness through that kind of
mirroring okay children acting as
mirrors and mirrors being part of the
oneness I'm so interested in this what
is a mirror mirror I mean if we speak
about the one that will look into it's a
reflection of ourselves and I believe
our innate nature reflects us on
ourselves is through the other people or
relationships our connection with them
all the other aspects that we experience
that's I would say is this conscious
mirroring that we actually experience
and unfortunately those mirrors are
quite neutral so they mirror what they
see or what is in front of them which
means if we are good people
it mirrors more geared and if we are bad
people
it mirrors more of that so that's why we
also see this cultural differences in
different locations and community
differences depends on what is there
that has been mirrored and I'm amplified
unfortunately is this like when someone
walks up to me and says like are you
okay maybe I am I'm feeling sad
or maybe someone says oh you know you
you look anxious there are two
possibilities in all of these situations
because people also reflect their own
inner world outside that's the
projection side of it so sometimes it's
a mirror of how I'm actually feeling and
then sometimes it's their projection of
their own inner world so here we go you
discern here we go we don't need to okay
okay guys we have one okay
we don't need to we don't need to
because the self reflection is exactly
the same as a projection these
projectors ourselves to the mirror so
that the mirror can actually reflect
back on us and because we are one it's
loop and it's constant continuously in
like the can interaction is can be
separable so so when someone walks up to
me and says you know are you anxious
right now it's both a lesson for them in
projection as well as a lesson for me in
mere understanding that I'm actually
anxious actually for you it's a signal
that most likely you would need to take
it as a invitation to speak about their
anxiousness because they are projecting
it out and you are the mirror in that
case oh oh interesting so there'd be an
invitation we'd ask them are you anxious
you would know that they are because
they are asking if I am but what if I'm
actually like expressing like anxiety if
it's like super visible okay yeah and it
is like super unquestionable then they
most likely won't even ask they would
just say okay ho what can I do for you
yeah yeah if it's you got it yes but
then if it's just like a borderline
there is more expressing this projection
because they feel themselves and they
have noticed those tiny details that are
expressing in you potentially to provoke
them to think about it and just to
reconfirm that for them wow isn't that
amazing that's mind-blowing
yeah it is
interesting so so when when things come
up like a mirror like that it's an
invitation for us to inquire about the
projection of what was coming up at that
time because it's a non clearly like
it's not like someone's like crying sad
okay
interesting interesting good and glad I
walk down that okay okay how about the
overall purpose of creation purpose is
necessary otherwise there is this lack
of direction and if people don't have a
direction they they go nowhere and they
go in cycles and actually the quite
destructive can be so when we speak
about individual lives organizations
businesses societies countries there has
to be a purpose and we've seen and
evidence that there might be companies
started and they end because they don't
really are they don't have a clear
purpose so they when I speak with my
students at the business school and I
asked this very fundamental question for
the business school what's business so
students naturally conventionally answer
well that's making money and I say
really then tell me what's money and
there is silence in the audience and
then but that's obvious money is money
and this is how I see that the cultural
projection on what is money as an
instrument and business as from my
perspective as the organized value
creation is not communicated even to the
business school students which is the
essential birth of the business
entrepreneurship so therefore I think
purpose is something that is essential
to us if we pay attention to it yeah and
we have evidence that not always the
societies and businesses and
organizations have the awareness and
consciousness to put it into their
agenda people wake up in the morning
without purpose they do their connection
to the virtual world they do their
routines without a purpose the purpose
is get through the day at like the
minimum that some people have some
people don't and then that's the end of
their lives but generally yes purpose I
think it's what is the first step
towards enlightenment so because you
kind of feel that you are belonging to
something to the unity of of the people
and the mankind mm-hmm and then is there
a purpose for creation creation in
itself is part of our nature so this is
how we have created things around us and
I think why we are here at this
conference right now is because we have
faced that things created around us have
excelled further away from or they have
been developed with the pace that is
much faster that is ahead of our own
human evolution and I think this is what
the time is when we start to realize
that we actually have to create
something for ourselves and actually we
have to create more of a self awareness
and more connection to whatever we call
it consciousness oneness universe and
deal with that because there is this
huge gap and because technologies are
excelling faster because of their
capabilities we are getting this gap too
wide and that's also one of the reasons
why we have there's backfires backfires
you know for the different age groups
starting from the kids addiction from
the technologies and ending with the
adults addicted to money for example
why would creation make this reality a
reality is as it is reality is and then
we use our capacity with given power of
our brains to interpret it to the best
of our abilities and if we speak about
creation as such I think this is how our
bodies creates energy from producing
food I mean the creation is kind of the
essential mini process that there's just
ongoing for everything at the same time
and then when people attach the word
creativity we mean something to create
out of non existent create something
that never existed and then there is
something new but I think creation it's
a part of the whole lifecycle which
happens all the time the Xuan's that was
in that was in latin the cells recreate
themselves all the time so this kind of
a creation is just just happening all
the time so people just added this layer
that okay we are sometimes more creative
sometimes less created they judge it by
the output but I think this creation is
just naturally forming all the time
and right now we are embedded in this
creation and we find ourselves at this
point where it seems like the most
upstream issue is our illusion of
separation do you feel like that's the
most upstream issue is the illusion of
separation from the one well yet that
could be one way to describe it
delusions are part like huge part of our
experiences even if we look back to our
brains
people predominately think they are
great they are as great as they are if
you look at the optical illusions you
have all many people had experiences
with seeing different illusions in the
books or somewhere else and most of them
have nothing to do with illusions it's
reality it's the illusion because the
brain cannot process it the way how its
projected on it and that's why it's the
people kind of views this world of
illusion but essentially it's it we can
call them brain failures because the
brain cannot process it the way how it's
given to it so therefore yes delusions
about separateness and creating more
awareness of who we really are and
that's what a spiritual speakers always
speak about this okay so this most
upstream issue of our illusion of
separateness is also actually this
greatest teaching function of us
understanding the truth of reality the
oneness right reality is again the
construct that we've created and we try
to make meaning or create the meaning
around this perception of reality and
then we can look at the technologies the
virtual reality the augmented reality
extended reality but then what about
human reality yeah what the humans
experience as the reality for themselves
including the example that I just
explained about the brain so-called
failures that's the reality for humans
and this discussion about brain being
counterpart counterpart to interpreting
the reality to the degree that it's
capable and then if the brain
experiences limitations then the reality
is limited so that's an I think a way of
understanding ourselves better in
relation
with the reality as we know it how has
your drop rejoined the ocean feelings of
interconnectedness or ego loss or
unconditional love the presence any of
these how have you experienced your drop
rejoining the ocean I am still in a way
experiencing like many of those things
and one of the most tangible or most
visible things for myself I've listed on
my five-year goals but it doesn't matter
like five or one or two it's just the
essence of it to become a true forgiver
mm-hmm
that's the goal it's very clearly in my
mind and in my awareness and in my let's
say direction towards that because we
know forgiveness is only for the person
who is forgiving himself
I mean forgiveness is given conceptually
to the other person but actually the
salvation is for the person who is who
is forgiving and I think that's the way
one of the practices how to get back the
balance in your life
so if if you maybe hit me with a ruler
or something you know and I'm like ow
and then you go I'm sorry who you
forgive me and I say yes that
forgiveness is for you this was very
kind of example that might not describe
the full potential of forgiveness
because most of the times when people
really suffer is when they don't forgive
or cannot forgive somebody who have done
like a larger harm like it's something
that is hard to forgive let's do an
example like a very serious like maybe
just
sheep-like cheating in a monogamous
relationship maybe is that a good
example or what would be a good one oh
there are linked from someone in whatsit
there all are bad examples because
that's a bad behavior but in terms of of
example let's say scientists invented a
new thing and didn't patent it and just
had told somebody about this invention
and then the other person just took it
and patented it and took it as his own
okay how would you feel if that's how
would I feel if I told you you invented
something so interesting because most
recently with these feelings of oneness
I just as Holmes this is so hard to say
but technically it's all for us it's all
one so then it's like a perfectly fine
you agree with that ok but most of the
people still or a large light portion of
people would still be very disappointed
like angry like okay how come and even
if that person might be a good friend
that's even like hurts more and then the
person who invented actually but now is
disappointed and angry brings that
feeling all the way all the life in the
person which means there is no space for
creation there is no space for love
there is no space for playfulness there
is no space all the space is taken with
the rumination around that anger yes
that thing ok so then if I'm doing the
classic anger around the stealing of
intellectual property let's say then my
whole life becomes consumed with that ok
and then you ask me for forgiveness is
that what's happening
no no then what then what yeah then what
yeah the magic lies in the fact that it
doesn't require an external think I ask
myself for forgiveness even further than
that he just do
forgive I do forgiveness
yes that's internal forgiveness that
that inner process when you take that
whichever form works for people there
can be different but then the person who
invented and then was disappointed just
does this practice on himself or herself
saying that happened and I forgive that
person for what the person dead and that
forgiveness ends the situation and the
anger is gone and the frustration is
gone if it's true forgiveness which
means I forgive that person for what the
person did and analyze like the way how
you responded because if it's really
oneness that forgiveness makes sense
right there like without even having
that experience of the anger but when
that experience of the anger has
happened then the day when the person
who gives internally it has almost
nothing to do with external external can
be before that after that but the
essential point of release of that
unwanted energy when I wanted a stored
energy which goes nowhere to the waste
question if we forgive the liar cheater
stealer etc then it happens again does
it not that's a conventional way of
thing it's not it doesn't happen again
then they wake up and they say oh I've
been forgiven I shall no longer like
cheater steal again a we can and we can
have like a spectrum of reactions okay
in this question but again if we speak
from the perspective of oneness yes they
feel like oh this is what's possible
forgiveness is possible okay so okay so
upon being forgiven and let's say
immediately after committing some sort
of malevolent act then the process of I
forgive that ignorant act act of
ignorance they do not know upon which
they cause harm it is you affecting the
one by doing so okay I forgive and then
you yourself realize oh I was forgiven
for that
I must make sure I do not commit such
malevolence again that is hopefully the
most optimist it's there also has this
flavor of analytical rational yeah but
then own emotional innate human level
it's more like what was that hmm I never
experienced this I never had this this
is something new and then the body
reacts to it like it it's pleasurable
like I got this he forgave me for this
and then they became aware of that
existence of forgiveness that will might
not had happen ever in their lives
and this is the this is the provoked
provoked in their bodies some
biochemical reaction and then the the
brain neurons like say oh this was an
interesting new circuit in our brains
let's and then once they experience it
once they will be more aware the next
time and the more over the next time and
more people will forgive for what they
whatever they do there would be more and
more awareness of this forgiveness being
all around them so well they would be
like questioning themselves
I like your depth dive into the feeling
the the visceral emotion that then
arises when that forgiveness happens
does it ever feel as though the process
sounds like forgiveness in many ways is
so this unconditional love but you have
an unconditional love even in the act of
someone doing something malevolent let's
say does it ever feel as though then
that those with unconditional love may
be conquered by those who choose to
technically everything can happen
depends on situation and and and and
everything else but if we go this way
which you just described we very quickly
come to the point that openness and
unconditional love is the strongest
fundamental step on
so people when they realize that this
person has that power of being and
sharing unconditional love which is
unaccessible for the other person so the
first impression will be okay I will
take advantage because this is just this
lame person loving everyone I will take
something and then they realize it's
very quickly that this is that end for
them because that person is gonna be
having this unconditional love forever
yeah and they're not getting triggered
by again and this like they are not in a
game yeah and those testers are
short-term games what is interesting
okay so so so this question is in a
sense it is has some sort of a basis in
in in fear in a way yes and so this is
very interesting because it's as though
it's like enlighten ourselves to all
love and then at the same time there's
this like but if those that are only
love driven will we not be taken over by
those who don't care whatsoever about
love and just want all of it for
themselves to be the gods of themselves
etc so there is but holding space for
that absolute highest reality though the
one where it is all unconditional love
that's the future that all of us know is
possible and that we want to guide
towards that future I'm gonna collapse
towards that probability future is just
the concept because of the time the time
that appeared with a stick in the ground
and a shadow moving and people say oh we
can follow this so therefore the future
is a concept for our consciousness
because in consciousness doesn't exist
it's all at the same time so which means
if we project in the future we actually
put a little bit of the boundary on
ourselves so the love is now and it's
fully accessible and I think just by
giving more and more reference to it and
more and more stepping on it it just is
and evolves and also it becomes more
accessible for those people so I believe
the reason that
kind of a big fight love versus hate is
just that there is a love versus less
awareness of love or less experience of
the love which might be not experienced
on this by a physiological level for
whatever reasons it was absent of the
experiences but I think that's that's
what is and then it's the question of
accessing it so we can be deeply
immersed into the feelings of
interconnectedness and unconditional
love on a moment-to-moment basis we can
be present with that yet there is some
sort of a a future that is being built
right time being the solution yes yes
yes of course yet there is some sort of
a future that is coming in this next
moment and then that next one and then
we're just slowly getting to those
moments there will be a moment when this
interview ends etc it's still a
projection of our mind a rational mind
have the notion of time so if you look
to their primitive brains and that we
share with animals so they don't have
this future and past kind of thing it's
the moment ok I'm hungry I'm angry I'm
disturbed I'm sleeping and that kind of
thing so if we really go down into or go
into or open us up for the consciousness
as it's in the purest form
the sequencing of the events is the
product of our brain intellectual part
on a solution part of the brain that has
the time as the construct and then
attached the events in the sequence yeah
and that's the way how bimba training it
so therefore it might sound like a very
provocative but it has different nature
on the same reality so we might actually
use it for when it's necessary and we
might not use it where it's maybe not
that applicable but so far brains have
been trying to fight to I see every
situation we interview right ok but then
it's also the complete illusion of it no
beginning no end no separation just all
one
and that we then like you gave the
example of the animals the the states of
your dog's consciousness see this is the
dog never ever contemplating death or
ever I don't build I never had a
conversation with any dog so far you
don't talk to dogs
yeah I can just gave up I just I just
bad at interpreting what they say
talking about talking to trees earlier
today as well so we've been all over the
that's really I mean and again it's so
interesting people talk to themselves in
their heads and why not to everything
else how do you how do you execute your
goals because if there is no time here
is being about goals another construct
in my work on transformation goal is
danger goals are danger yes what yes
ambition is danger
the ambition is not the goal
so ambition can have a form of a goal or
form of a direction okay so how about
direction that's a couple of different
than the goal yes what I heard that goal
is okay as long as there's no attachment
to when it happens that's that's more
direction right within the paradigm that
goals are necessary there is a there is
a theory goal-setting theory for example
but then the limitation of all of that
work that implies goal implies that
there will be a moment when you reach it
and then what and they have been studies
and there have been practical examples
those milestones and now you put the
milestones on the line and on the line
that is leading somewhere look at this
direction and in the work that I do
about that policy of change there three
types there are three types of team
change change yes first type is
transactional so it's a one-time change
you just exchange your money for a gym
membership
or whatever or for the conference with
it which might not say anything about
you going to the conference or going to
the gym you just did a transaction with
a good intention to actually do a change
in your life transaction one-time thing
second is transition transition is like
a line so the first one is like a dot
the other was like a line it has a
duration it's a period of time okay so
you might say I'm gonna go I'm actually
using this gym for a year okay cool and
you actually go three times a week yeah
an expectation is that after a year you
will continue and you re subscribe and
that's again that's a that's a delusion
that it's gonna happen it's just a hope
but what it says to our psychology we
put ourselves let's say in a mental jail
for a year and waiting for the release
date to come and we go very consistently
three days a week because we are
consistent with the commitment but
psychologically we wait because we know
there will be end to it and that's why
goals show something that is like a
relief and you cannot wait for it
therefore that third type of change is
transformational which means you remove
remove and that's the secret which I am
sell information is the secret no the
secret what differs from the transition
which is a line to transformation you
remove the endpoint and becomes an arrow
which points a direction where you want
to go and it's endless and the endless
requires identity change because you
need to go back to yourself and ask
yourself who do I need to become to
actually walk this arrow all the time
let me give you a very trivial example
especially in many countries which do
smoke and prior to this example you we
have the dot which is the transaction we
have a line which has some sort of a
goal and like an end point where you
feel relief that you've achieved the
goal otherwise I can just change it into
an infinite arrow an infinite arrow
towards the flowering of consciousness
and very and then I can just become that
I
go to self-work and I become that it's
real growth it requires you to revisit
yourself your identity
imagine you are a book and describes
your status today and if that for
example for a one person includes I I do
smoke ten cigarettes a day that's what's
written in the book today and that
really represents the reality of that
person and on January first the person
makes a new year's resolution I'm not
gonna do it anymore I'm not gonna smoke
and he or she does it already for five
consecutive years I'm not gonna be
smoking and that happens every January
so now if the person says I'm not gonna
smoke for three months with a hope that
after the three months I will just
create this new habit and it will gonna
last this is what the trap is so the
psychological trap of waiting for the
three-month and actually consistently
doing it but then psychology didn't
change because there wasn't need to
revisit your identity and rewrite that
sentence in your book what is required
and what and the difference is if you
say this is an arrow which means for
forever and you cannot be in conflict
with yourself for forever so you need to
revisit that's also realizing that
theory of cognitive dissonance your
attitude and your behavior have to be
consistent so in that case if you see no
end point there is no thing to grab on
that's is this is why so many people do
cold-turkey styles of quitting where
they just decide to cessation of smoking
for life director arrow and then that's
this whole cold turkey thing I don't
know about cold turkey that's what we
this is what it's called Louie you said
this is just a decision sometimes that
people make just stop
I call it chess type of mindset
I didn't you ass it's Jeff's yeah the
black and white black and white oh yes
you either or you play black or you play
white you either smoke or you stop
completely wait a minute
okay you either smoke
what's the opposite you don't you don't
because when you phrase it you stop you
imply you you did and when you apply you
did you reference to the past and
against it and construct your identity
is the book today okay either it has the
sentence or it doesn't have the sentence
and it there is no point to referring
back to the history because it's not you
anymore which I say I don't smoke
yeah then and then that's what I wrote I
don't that word specifically I do not
yeah currently which does not include
any time it only talks about present
identity identity that dated the
question and the way to trigger the
identity is to remove that the goal I
don't say that it's wrong I just say if
we want sustainable change which is
transformation that's more successful
goals have been proven to be successful
to be achieved but then we have seen
that some people backfire after that and
some people are aware to back and so the
goal is still limitation in time arrow
is endless so that's why it's transfer
very transformational and then again
coming back to the smoking example that
I wanted to say imagine this arrow and
then every single decision which is a
transaction has to land on that arrow as
you move every day and you have the same
friends offering you cigarettes and then
you have this meetings and everything
else and your habits are still
triggering you but you're just making
decisions small decision every time
no and you look at your book I don't
smoke it's your book oh yeah and we know
we sometimes can be weak that's our
nature and there might be a bad day you
had a dispute with the colleague and you
have I may be damaged your car whatever
has happened flat tire or something and
you stand there and there it is for
example you have the flat tire for a car
and there is this guys coming to pick up
your car and they stand let's look what
to do and they start to smoke and you
feel bad like like the
like stressed and you think okay this is
so exceptional so this is the only flat
tire in last 10 years and this is I'm
I'm missing my flight and like all of
this crazy and they have this cigarettes
right around and and that there's a very
tempting at that moment but the here is
the truth as soon as you take that
cigarette that decision don't land on
the arrow it lands slightly near and
geometrically it means a different arrow
so you land yourself on a different
arrow which leads to a different end
point so you're not actually heading
where you wanted but you've slightly a
one degree two degrees off a track which
means your identity is somewhere else in
the future and that's how it's different
people brains actually are so smart that
they create delusions that the brain
thing says I'm controlling everything
you just do this and then we will revert
you back to the arrow but that's not how
the geometry works
you automatically are in a different one
and that's the delusion and why brains
do it because brains don't want to put a
lot of cognitive effort in too many
things just avoid pain more pleasure
that's the formula of the brain but the
brains are as we discussed they are not
perfect so we need to understand them
better and also understand that it's
just a one part of our body and there is
a subconscious brain there are neural
networks in heart in the gut and so
forth so we have to end the supremacy of
the logical brain we set a directional
trajectory towards I our identity being
something like wanting the highest
possible not even wanting but just
towards the direction towards the
highest possible state of what this
could be this creation could be and
there may be some discourse that happens
to figure out between people to figure
out what is that exact highest possible
place for creation to be
anytime leaf the these circumstances
like you gave may cause our confidence
to waver slightly from that highest
possible and if we do decide to in a
sense succumb to that those
circumstances that then our arrow of
direction changes very very so slightly
because that transactional moment is
plotted on a one-degree let's say
difference this is so interesting
because I view it so much on this kind
of like like if like the like you're
like your x-axis being something like ah
like like time yes and your y-axis being
something like like your highest highest
potential like I'm always trying to help
people like go like this like up as fast
as possible towards your highest
potential in the least amount of time
but like a lot of the times we
experience things that just cause us to
go yeah just like this way right and by
time you die you're just like [ __ ] I
haven't done what I wanted to well is
blueprinted to do and so that kind of
speaks to these like bifurcating moments
that happen all like all the time that
like you know you're on your trajectory
and you maybe wrote in your book that
you don't do something and then given
the conditions maybe you know rather
than going this way you go a little bit
this way because you chose at that
moment and then yeah go ahead there is a
possibility for always to have an arrow
that deviates from the original one but
that decision has to be very deliberate
and again it has to be with intention to
have it to have a new arrow let me give
you an example so people buy the
membership or to the gym they go to the
gym and then they get better and they
get fitter and then they meet somebody
who says Oh
do so well that specific thing why don't
you become a semi-professional and
that's a new career that's a new
opportunity and if the person feels good
about that then they say okay my new
like old arrow was be fit and the new
arrow is to do some semi-professional
activities so they at that point they
divert from that arrow because they
don't want to be in the end just fit
they want to be a semi-professional
athlete and that's what's perfectly fine
but that uncovers the difference between
the very firm redirection and these
small tempting moments that can happen
yes okay yes so yeah there's the bat the
bifurcating moments it's not only
towards like the tempted tempted of like
distractions that can happen I'm away
from your highest but it can actually
potentially the bifurcations can be like
a mentor that gives you really good
advice that you take and then it Rockets
you forward stuff like that the same
thing the same thing and maybe just to
add a little bit the arrow usually is
perceived to point away from us the time
arrow usually points away from us the
future is in front the history is in at
the back but essentially if we speak
about oneness yeah you know the arrow
actually points inwards inwards and it's
endless inwards endless inwards so we
are uncovering us ourselves and we are
live pulling off the layers of
conditioning and layers of unknown and
doing doing this arrow arrow of our own
being who we are is actually inwards and
therefore again there it's it's timeless
a timeless arrow of inward yeah is
potentially this purpose that's the
creation yes this is how we get into our
highest being from which we create
unimaginable things pretty much anything
we need
there's this lots of joy is present
right now and it feels like it's due to
the deeper and deeper process of
uncovering the beautiful silly playful
fun game of truth of creation why it's
so enlightening is because this is this
is our nature and we collectively
together in this conversation and other
conversations are get closer and closer
and we share yeah do you remember the
movie matrix oh yeah why do you bring it
up there will be metrics for coming out
soon yes but then I use in in my talks
30 seconds from the first matrix okay
the iconic moment when the first time
Neil meets Morpheus yes and Morpheus
says no one can be told what the matrix
is so therefore no one also can be told
what true nature of our being is yes you
can only see it for yourself
here is the blue pill here is the red
pill you take the blue pill you wake up
in the morning believe whatever you want
to believe it say the red pill the story
ends and I show how deep the rabbit hole
goes and the rabbit hole is there it's
here no arrow in words
the rabbit hole is the eternal arrow
inwards yeah yeah we can speak in the
metaphors
yeah yeah that's beautiful yeah it's
already 20 years ago in one of the
iconic movies yeah and you would ask
people around the globe people would
know this movie just like Fight Club for
example and others they know the scene
they know the pills yeah how many of
them would ever think what the
rabbit-hole means for themselves yeah
yeah so so it's a so then it's a it's a
it's an a decision of our identity in
our book to say and decide that I will
do the eternal arrow inward here it says
again will imply as future okay oh I am
doing the eternal arrow inward i I am I
am the eternal arrow inward yeah just
make it simple
yeah same simple works better yeah yeah
it does yeah I am the eternal arrow
inward means you've taken the red pill
and you're exploring the depth of the
rabbit hole of creation and stack them
up as the French would say that's the
way it goes goes the the depth of the
arrow inward is infinite and that's the
games these are the infinite games of
that we play exactly and that's why it's
so enlightening because it never ends
and just keep on playing
is there anything more beautiful than
this creation there no here yes so the
big nothing's more beautiful in that but
here again I was just playing with the
place what were you yeah yeah so here
and there I played with time okay and
now now we play with space okay they're
in here
it's all here that's all here yes yes
sorry for that is there anything more
beautiful than this infinite game not to
my awareness so it's safe to say that
there's nothing more beautiful it's
impossible for something to be more
beautiful than creation exactly because
the rest is our delusion of seeking for
something external that has been proven
to be more easier to possibly get or
create or access those are the shortcuts
those are the short-term pain and
pleasure game that's somewhat is part of
our life because of our evolution but
then again I think our human potential
is much higher than that and again I I
think the most interesting part in this
game right now is really if we look at
the inion yes it's one part is the pain
and pleasure which is a short terminus
of everything let me have this cigarette
let me have this drink let me get this
car let me get this house let me jump on
my head into the pool and the eternity
on the other hand this infinite arrow
inwards which actually is the essence of
who we are and those are the two forces
I think that this that both are
maintained in our
how many six pounds of jelly like mass
with the biochemical signals that we
trying to grasp understanding which is
our brain and the more we become aware
of our true nature and then our game
becomes more in favor of the internal
arrow rather than the pain and pleasure
which has been dominating for hundreds
of years
I'm worried thousands so so it's safe to
say that then in indigeneity the
infinite arrow inward is dominant and
that in metropolis life the pain
pleasure side is dominant but
essentially that's an oversimplification
but yeah oversimplifying they have been
with us always it's just that we've been
evolving to feel more of the infinite
arrow because we were very busy to
feeding ourselves and surviving and
running out running away from big
animals and that's all about surviving
and pleasure and pain that is constantly
still maintained by our instinctive
brain or the primitive brain which
predominantly reacts fast and therefore
also once for the fast pleasure or
quickly avoid pain and that's the
short-term Nisour fastness of their
primitive brain and because we developed
all this analytical rationale and
therefore also slow actually giving us
the possibility to play this other part
more efficiently comparing maybe to the
older days we were busy of surviving so
I don't think we will ever transcend
fully the pain and pleasure part because
that's the biology for example we need
food and then that's we that's the
pleasure is through the carbon hydrates
and that we get and it's fulfilled so we
need that
the instrumentality or body is built
this way it's it's but is this true
though that you feel like you relate
more with indigeneity on pain pleasure
then then you and relate with them on a
complete interconnectedness with each
other in their environment and source
and the infinite arrow inward because I
relate with them more on that than I do
on like ah looking for danger
oh I'm under attack I need to you know
leave we were in there not me no you so
it's difficult for me to say what
exactly happened and now we are trying
to project something on them where we
never been I would say we always had
both it was my what I'm saying is that
the pair that this portion of one or the
other has changed depending on the
circumstances so if the circumstances
for a particular period of time required
more surviving clothing housing animals
disasters they didn't have that possibly
much time to contemplate on the inward
arrow of course they did of course they
did community they did spiritual things
and they did at a level of their
comprehension that a period of time but
I wouldn't say that they would be fully
living this life maybe in some parts of
the world where the danger was less so
they were not triggered and food was
abundant of course it was like that and
as well if their immediate return under
gatherers it's always abundance it's
never scarcity there's always enough but
you're right these are all thoughts
about yeah yeah I'm also just curious
about like like where is things where
are things going
because it does feel like humanity is
some sort of a biological bootloader
for a digital super intelligence
how do you feel about that I really
think the way how we see reality is a
tournament by the words that we use
framing it so we can say where all of us
are going or well where this world is
going and you can say oh what is coming
actually so what is the next thing that
we can experience so it's not that we
kind of am moving away towards a new
world where there will be different
things but actually what we are
welcoming in our lives so actually we
are here and things are coming
innovations are coming experiences are
coming self evolution is coming into our
lives and that also changes the
perspective because if we are need to go
then we get into the rushing something
into the speeding up into getting
stressed about it but if we are taking
the perspective that our creation is
coming to us that we are going after the
creation so then again we have
completely different perspective and
then we choose what we welcome to what
we welcome in yeah
all the possibilities exist and then our
present moment whatever we welcome in if
we welcome in fear or love or if we
welcome in the future of whatever future
we welcome in future that we welcome in
is where it ends up going that how they
the Game Awards happen yes so if I have
a but if I if there's so many different
possibilities possibilities and I'm only
welcoming in the highest possibility and
if that highest possibility does not
come if it doesn't include us becoming
multiplanetary and then the asteroid
comes that's the fear speaking is it
really the fear speaking or is it
foresight that you want the highest to
be multiplanetary so that it can
preserve remember the mirrors in the
beginning of our conversation che what's
that the fear is a good projector okay
fear can create that there will be
somebody throwing a stone in this window
and will ruin all of this conversation
what there might be the fear that there
will be electricity off and we would
need to really record all of this sued
the whole conversation about the
collision of an asteroid killing all the
dinosaurs this doesn't like you know
that it just doesn't feel like it can
happen again or essentially it doesn't
have pretty much anything to do with our
being here I mean the way how we
experience this is so interesting it
isn't it it doesn't ever feel like
there's like too much like lost miss
that can come from being so immersed in
the present or in just unconditional
love or just this infinite inward arrow
where you where you just it never comes
up that hey maybe we should get to
another celestial body maybe it's
interesting to explore that that's
perfectly fine if it has a good purpose
remember we spoke about the intention
purposes yes yes then we could point the
arrow towards getting there yes and it
has a purpose then we go there okay yeah
yeah fine that's fine oh you but not
from a place of fears what you're saying
from the asteroid colliding but it's
from a place of exploration or necessity
or necessity so instead of fear instead
of telling the story about pass right we
just say it's necessary to explain we
have discovered the necessity to find
resources Oh remiss the city to find
resources because we want a hundred
zillion we're 100 billion humans instead
of just eight we want sustain the
possibility for everyone to experience
fullest creativity and for that because
we get more we need more resources we
need more resources or biological ok so
we want consciousness to experience as
many degrees of freedom as I can to
pursue its own creative loving
endeavoring and we need resources for
that therefore there is necessity and
therefore we become interplanetary
interstellar and we explore rather than
asteroid fear yeah that's so that's
interesting I have that I much prefer
that the story told that way as well as
more science it is more beautiful you
your body reacts more with pleasures to
this alternative rather than the
asteroid yeah my bot reacted with a lot
of pleasure feeling these two
differences in learning about the best
story to tell because the other this one
is very inspirational
it's very heroic it's like the your
children their children generations of
children will be able to endeavor into
consciousness and pursue what is most
creative and meaningful because there
will be so many resources as we become
interstellar and Planetary they might be
there's kind of specific cells that just
fly autonomously in the space and
there's like a one passenger thing and
then you just like
navigated through the space anywhere you
want with any speed and your kids are
just exploring that and having this
expansion of the mind beyond what can
imagine what we can imagine today oh
your consciousness goes
completely different picture same the
same arrow yeah or that that could be
also possibly compared but there was a
goal avoid the asteroid and here's the
narrower foot but like expanding the
potential or depending there what was
interesting that you said that the arrow
was in a sense pointed in the same
direction but with a different story
we then usually corrected and said it
was a goal but I it is kind of but the
oh oh maybe the arrow in this case is
survival you see or thriving right yeah
you see what brought my attention to
correct myself because the asteroid is a
point in time the line ends with
asteroid hits hazard yes yes okay that's
why there's this goal I see the line
ends yeah there's a point yeah it's a
point as a point in somewhere there
while expansion of our consciousness and
exploration and more resources is
endless interesting so which we should
be telling stories that are only about
the this this infinite arrow in this
infinite game of inward that are that
have an intention of love and growth and
prosperity and these more beautiful
adventurous words rather than ones that
are fearful I mean should never then
tell the stories is that right there's
never never there's never a purpose for
the fear story yeah you know we discuss
the the mechanics of our expansion
through the arrow and pointing it but we
don't need to use that metaphor every
single time we speak about certain
things
but you were very rightly said that we
would be projecting or
directing the arrow towards love towards
compassion towards expansion towards
creativity and then as we are pointing
it we just pull in the context and then
speak about things provide things and
explain things and encourage people and
engage people by making it making the
direction more into their awareness and
they oh yeah that would make sense if we
went to this interstellar and the the
resources and there's new possibilities
to expand our awareness about things
that would be very enlightening that
would be experience expansive experience
and oh why not and then we point arrows
towards novel spaceships novel
technology is that actually or
components on this journey and so you
put those onto the arrow so you do the
spaceships you do their
AI you do the next thing you do the new
materials and all of this land on the
arrow and the arrow points towards
interstellar life mm-hmm and then every
everybody of every cell in the
consciousness says well how's this thing
okay okay I see so so the so so the the
intention and the very serious process
of of self work in understanding this
this infinite game and putting that
intention of that infinite arrow towards
that love and growth prosperity all
these words it then makes it so that
there is no potential errors that happen
in terms of our ethics or morals or
philosophies or issues that could arise
from when we make the technologies like
artificial intelligence or biotech neuro
tech etc
there's no rather than selling the story
of the fear you're selling the story of
the purpose the purpose and just the
absolutely unwavering focus no swaying
away from that only yes and just to
remind that on every time on while we're
moving on that Harrow we can realize
while we've got this new attack which
would actually give us experience to
accelerate our progress and therefore
means we can aim for even higher
expansion which would be a new arrow
from that moment of realization and we
say okay are we willing to go the same
way or we see this potential redirecting
us and why don't we after this discovery
reconsider harrowing us there and then
we just say wow that has even greater
potential of expansion by just moving
there so we can always point a new arrow
out of existing one but very
deliberately so it has to be with a good
purpose okay and that's these dialectics
that happen between the kind of like the
dialogue of the civilization etc that
could then decide on the the slight
adjustments of the purpose arrow that's
the collective that's a collective
awareness how do we make it like a
decentralized way to make the decision
of the civilizations purpose arrow and
that's an interesting topic we would be
discussing also here at the conference
my work previously was around figuring
out because I was working on
transforming cities so what would be the
universe so well-being scale so for
example there is a land available in a
city and then it would be different
developers proposing different projects
parking garage park supermarket basic
things
and typically people who look at the
expenses the resources and readily they
would be really going into the impact to
the to the well-being of people around
that to the earth to the ecosystem all
of those sort of things but if we were
if we had this Universal metric it would
land somewhere from one from zero to
hundred percent for example news three
projects depending on the universal
collective impact to everything what is
meaningful for us and what would have
the highest purpose so that we'll have
this collective set of things that would
emerge as a one variable on this one
metric and if we get that done then I
think we are pretty good at collectively
deciding what it is and then
collectively adjust adjusting if you
need it so and that's not trivial but
also not too complicated because I think
or current mindsets are too locked into
the previous habits money cost and then
maybe the corporate social
responsibility emerged I didn't know a
couple of decades ago and now it's more
and more other well-being things come to
the workplace and so forth I just think
that if we become more conscious and
aware we could speed up that process of
actually getting this universe so I
always speaking about the universal
well-being my trip but I now during this
conference are more and more
contemplating with universal
consciousness mature and that would be
amazing and I think that would be
reference point and it could be shared
with everyone and then cultures can old
places can adapt depending on their
values because values is something that
is fundamental day societies and
communities the universal consciousness
metric that is adjusted based on the
values of the
I wouldn't predict there would be a huge
differences based on the values but
values are always that fundamental for
the local community therefore they have
to be part of that so what I mean is
some people are more collectivist
somewhere more competitive I didn't say
which one like one is better than the
other but if they are this way you can
adopt the the measurement instrument
yeah holding to the talents to the
values and then there's still some sort
of a way to decide on what even these
measurement the measurement instrument
is in the first place based on who
decides you know that's hard it's again
it's nothing your connectedness like
based on your your biometric state of
interconnectedness and then maybe you're
enlightened enough to be one of the
ideas behind the purpose yeah I think
the purpose is something that would be
the common denominator and then it would
be very easy to understand contribute
contributions or determinants of that
and then that could give this maybe
there will be a lot of smaller
indicators dropping into larger
indicators and then we will get this the
holistic metric in the very end so the
universal consciousness metric and then
what I mean by adjusting to the value is
it might be the proportions so you might
have like a different input based on
what's more important in that specific
culture and that's let's say there are
10 categories by 10 percent
but then in one culture it would be
split of this 10 and 10 into 15 and 5 so
it like some some of the category is
more important than the other one so
there would be like rearranging more
percentage-wise like a weight different
kind of weights attached to the same
category I think the categories would
still remain very universal because they
attached to the purpose and the greater
purpose of the mankind anyways it was
just like like the implementation of
that part was specific yes but even at
the most
upstream though the overall
civilizational purpose though I mean
this isn't kind of reminds me also like
the Dunbar communities themselves just
so hard to go past that 150 and you jump
to figuring out how to govern a billion
people or eight billion people is much
more yeah there's there's different ways
to structure the social fabric to
maximize flourishing and so we're kind
of in the process of running all the
combinatorics permutations as little
governments and stuff right now and yeah
there's there's been a lot of really
interesting things that have come up
from this conversation yeah this has
been really fun organized thank you so
much for coming up new way to welcome I
mean this is life would you just let
ourselves live it and I just start you
know reach we just need to reach for it
you just need to some say concentrate
some say meditate we just need to allow
it to come it's everything is in our
reach you're very welcome thank you
thank you this was very very enjoyable
we've been honored it's been so fun they
have thank you thank you thanks thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode all these different interesting
fascinating multi area topics that were
covered this was so fun brother check
out the links song this is work in the
bio below check out all those links
check out the links to the
transformative technology conference as
well check out all those links Thank You
Brady stronger for co-producing we
really appreciate you and also support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
organizations the spiritual leaders
around the world that you believe in in
your local communities you can put some
unit simulation you support our show you
can find the links in the
below PayPal patreon cryptocurrency can
design design cool merch get paid and go
and build the future manifest your dream
since the world we love very much thank
you for tuning in and we will see you
soon peace
[Music]
you
[Music]